hello everyone and welcome to one of my
favorite Miniatures all together it is
ready versus the taco there in 1910 and
it's only 10 moves about what incredible
10 moves they are so just a standard
Karo Khan defense captures captures
Knight to F6 and here we have this
extremely rare Queen to D3 move which
should lose weight at Tempo but in the
game tartaker played the five captors
Queen to A5 check going after the E5
pawn bishop blocks Queen captures and
now ready Castle queenside uh seemingly
uh blundering a knight on e4 and
tatakover trusted him he played Knight
captures on e4 and here comes the the
Shocker Queen to d8 with check forces
the king into a double Discovery uh King
captures Bishop G5 a double check from
the rook and the bishop and that's just
it if you go to E8 Rook to d8 is
Checkmate and even better if you go to
C7 then Bishop to d8 this Checkmate so
there you have it hope you enjoy it
share it with your friends see you soon